it's me cat
Greg is still off skiing and says the
powder's been great which is weird for
this time of year in Colombia
because I don't really understand winter
sports but I'm happy to fill in again
and since I don't get the chance to do
this too often I want to do something
different see sometimes we hear on Fox
News can be a little hard on President
Biden every second it's he called
Republicans a threat to democracy this
or he seemed clueless while Afghanistan
collapsed that or middle class people
can't afford food
can we stop complaining for just one
second I want to take this opportunity
to highlight some of the most impressive
things we've seen from Joe during his
presidency
for one thing
he doesn't get enough credit for his
Devotion to the United States having its
first female president
yeah a lot of people in the past may
have said the future is female but Biden
is the only guy who thinks that that
future is now
now when President Harrison I took a
virtual tour of a vaccination Center in
Arizona she turned 30.
happy birthday great president uh all
kidding aside of course president Harris
is a proud Howard Alum last week
president Harris and I
stood in the United States capitol
yeah plenty of people want to want to
see a female president but he's the only
guy who already does
and he can see ghosts too
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you everyone always complains
about how the Democrats nominated an old
white guy but they didn't they nominated
the first Jewish Latin X
commander-in-chief
when Jill and I were vice president
first lady Jill and I honored we're
honored to host the first Rosh Hashanah
reception at the Naval Observatory I
probably uh went to shul more than many
of you did
you all think I'm kidding he can tell
you and so I I was sort of raised in the
Puerto Rican community at home
politically
hi dios mio
and of course shalom
meanwhile he's the most transparent
president we've ever had and don't let
anyone tell you otherwise I mean who
lets us see behind the scenes like Joe
Biden does
women are not without electoral or
political power
it is noteworthy that the percentage of
women who registered to vote and cast a
ballot is consistently higher than the
percentage of the men who do so end of
quote repeat the line women are not
without electoral and or political or or
maybe precise not and or political power
yeah
while other presidents just read what
they're supposed to read off the
teleprompter Biden's not afraid to read
everything
he really is a brave guy remember when
Robert Frost talked about taking The
Road Less Traveled no one does that
better than Joe
Mr Haney
the other one
he's such a Washington Outsider he's
always separating himself from the crowd
he also knows how to make people feel
really special even after they've passed
I want to thank all of you here for
including bipartisan electricians like
representative Governor Senator Braun
Senator Booker representative Jackie you
here where's Jackie I don't think she
wrote that she was going to be here
yeah While most people promise not to
forget you when you're gone Biden takes
it a million steps further and forgets
that you are gone
plus Biden is hot
you don't believe me look at this
[Applause]
that's right Biden is so irresistibly
sexy that even Christian icon the Easter
Bunny can't resist touching him
who can blame him Biden's so banging I
let him sniff my extensions any day or
night of the week
and let's not forget he's been doing all
of this while bravely battling a
horrific illness
first Frost you know what was happening
it had to put on your windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why I had so damn many other
people I grew up have cancer
for you and me
sir and I said so many of his friends
have oil cancer too and shame on us for
ignoring it so after all of this how can
you not believe that Joe Biden is a
strong feminist sex symbol a leader for
the ages a man of great repute
I mean what would the alternative be
that our president is just some guy who
screws up all the time America would be
in pretty bad shape if that were the
case unlike Joe Biden anniversary
[Applause]
all right let's welcome tonight's guest
when people see him on the street they
immediately stick out their tongues and
say ah host of Dr director after dark Dr
Drew Pinsky
why splurge on a Ferrari when you can
have a perfectly good Corolla host of
the Adam Carolla show Adam Carolla
she's always up in everybody's business
host of American Dream Home on Fox
Business Cheryl cassone
when he steps up to the plate the
pitcher runs home the nwa's World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus thank you
all right all right Dr Drew you are a
doctor yes ma'am wow yeah dude yeah I
would just want it Greg's the only
person ever said that to me before
you're done well I was gonna ask you how
many people have you personally treated
with oil cancer oh oil cancer like me
and many of my friends we all have moral
cancer but uh no I can't say I've had
any okay yeah wow shocking so what do
you what did you make of the year for
for Joe you know Adam and I discussed
both on our podcast and alone trying to
figure out what is up with him yeah we
really do
um and I lately am worried that he's
starting to confabulate a little bit uh
and that's what people do when their
faculty start to slip I'm sorry this is
no harm intended I hope hope this isn't
true but people will fill in with all
particularly if their personality
constructed a certain way and
politicians generally their personality
is constructed that way where the truth
is sort of maybe not such an important
matter but if you're as your cognitive
function as a client they will
confabulate and sort of fill in with
story yeah Adam I remember we were all
told that this would be you know Biden
would be like the return to normal did
any of that look normal to you well they
did the truth about the truth don't
forget no I mean a couple things so
everyone goes well he's getting older
and you know he's lost this few miles an
hour off his fastball but he's very
specific in his lying you know what I
mean like he's going my Uncle Frank gave
me Joey I need the Medal of Honor and I
shot him in a ladder that no he was dead
he never did that like yeah let me tell
you what happens when you get older I
have a dad who's 91. he's like uh you
should ask
what the hell is my wife's name again
yeah he doesn't go Scranton 1951. two
dudes kissing my son said my dad said
Joey this is the future like that's very
specific and then also this line goes
back to the 80s she was like top of my
class uh I I I had a had a full
scholarship and I I graduated with three
degrees like no no that's that's 80s
line so yeah it's not losing his
faculties it's more lying in a even more
specific bizarre way and to be fair it's
grandiose right yes this goes in a
certain direction only right only yeah
absolutely Cheryl is he actually
insulting
honest old people why wouldn't anyone
blames it on his age look I don't know
what's going on with him I'm just gonna
say he's slowed down a little bit and
I'm going to leave it there but you know
the people that he's put around him I
mean my gosh our president Kamala Harris
apparently who's the borders are she's
doing a fabulous job of taking care of
the Southern border so that's a big win
for him this week it's it's p budajesh
who's the real shining star in the
administration he appointed him he's
done a great job managing the the skies
in the airports everywhere Southwest
Airlines big example there so I don't
really know what's going on with him but
all I can say is right now margarine is
50 more expensive than it is and if I
cooked at home I'd be really upset
yeah I haven't done that in years did
you ever do that I did like years like
maybe eight or nine
dyrus do you think things will get
better in 2023 people say that they'll
be like new year new me is Joe gonna do
that well first of all I know the
audience was confused by the learner
doctor's assessment and I didn't
I think what he was trying to say in
layperson terms he's a artist that's
what he's trying to say he's fully
but just with all the gaffs in your
monologue that you showed and that was
like that was the polite version yeah
okay it was this year yeah and some of
them right you would never say anything
bad about an elderly person losing their
faculties but he's a liar he's an old
liar
that's it
[Laughter]
he is he is an old he's such a liar he's
such a liar well I mean who's his
Visiting Angel at this point that's my
question right I mean there's got to be
is it is it his wife I mean who's is it
the Easter Bunny apparently who's there
this guy George Stephanopoulos or
whatever the Republican guy he lies too
yeah I mean Santos yeah all the ones if
any of us like that's his real name if
if any of us you know behaved anything
close to that we would immediately be
sent home forever fine all right up next
musk encourages questions and gives
crybabies indigestion hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else